la invasión rusa ucrania entra en su
séptima semana mosco asegura que más de
mil soldados ucranianos se han rendido
en la ciudad clave de mariupol mientras
que quien lo desmiente estados unidos
reitera que califica la operación de
experian como genocidio y rusia rechaza
los señalamientos sobre un hipotético
uso de armas químicas
en francia avanza la campaña de las
elecciones presidenciales el mandatario
y candidato en manuel macro me habló de
su proyecto económico mientras que su
rival marine lepén asegura que pedirá un
acercamiento estratégico entre la otan y
rusia
ya está detenido el hombre acusado de
disparar y herir a más de 20 personas en
el metro de brooklyn tras una búsqueda
de más de 24 horas el sospechoso fue
hallado por la policía gracias a una
denuncia ciudadana el sujeto se enfrenta
a cargos federales de terrorismo
nueva emisión de noticias aquí en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nosotros yo soy juan
pupiales comenzamos esta emisión
hablando de la guerra en ucrania la
invasión rusa entra en la séptima semana
en moscú ha divulgado estas imágenes que
no han sido verificadas y con las que
asegura que más de mil soldados
ucranianos se han rendido en la asediada
ciudad de mariupol un importante punto
estratégico para las aspiraciones del
kremlin desde el ministerio del interior
de ucrania han rechazado esta versión de
moscú y aseguran que la batalla por la
urbe continúa mientras tanto rusia
desmintió la información entregada por
eeuu en la que asegura que moscú podría
usar armas químicas en las últimas horas
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski insistió en su llamado para
prohibir las importaciones de petróleo
ruso y llevar a sus oficiales ante la
justicia
en primer lugar necesitamos un embargo
al petróleo y la clara disposición de
europa a renunciar a toda la energía
rusa ior está unión europea debe dejar
de patrocinar la maquinaria militar de
rusia
que hable hoy con el presidente by the
end entre los temas de conversación
estuvo el enjuiciamiento de todos los
militares y comandantes rusos que
cometieron crímenes de guerra las cifras
en inglés joe en las próximas semanas
finlandia decidirá si presenta o no una
solicitud de adhesión a la otan rusia
amenazó con posibles eran represalias y
helsinki entra a formar parte de la
alianza militar suecia también se
plantea un eventual ingreso marina
sardenya con los detalles
finlandia podría convertirse en el
miembro 31 de la otan impulsada por la
guerra en ucrania el gobierno finlandés
debatirá el ingreso a la alianza en el
parlamento así lo anunció la primera
ministra reiterando que la decisión se
conocerán semanas y hay diferentes
perspectivas para solicitar el ingreso
en la otan o no solicitarlo y tenemos
que analizar todo esto muy
cuidadosamente como dijo magdalena y
tendremos esas discusiones dentro del
parlamento finlandés en las próximas
semanas schoeps white fast hero
happening weeks a summer
pero creo que nuestro proceso será
bastante rápido creo que tenemos que
tomar la decisión por nosotros mismos no
dejar que el miedo influya en nuestras
elecciones en las calles de la capital
helsinki los ciudadanos están cada vez
más a favor de integrarse a la alianza
encuestas recientes muestran hasta un
68% de la población en prop pero temen
las posibles represalias de la vecina
rusia con quién finlandia comparten 1300
kilómetros de frontera
y antes estaba en contra de entrar en la
otan pero hoy creo que es una opción
razonable defendible si definitivamente
creo que rusia ha mostrado su verdadera
cara así que creo que deberíamos entrar
en la otan
suecia por su parte también está
sopesando una eventual adhesión el
pasado lunes el portavoz del kremlin
dmitri peskov advirtió a suecia y
finlandia que no se unieran a la otan
amenazando con que rusia tendría que
reequilibrar la situación con sus
propias medidas aunque el ministro de
defensa finlandés asegura que el país no
enfrenta a una amenaza militar inmediata
para los próximos cuatro años el
gobierno ha decidido aumentar el
presupuesto de defensa en un total de
aproximadamente 2.200 millones de euros
para este año además aumentaremos el
presupuesto de defensa en
aproximadamente 700 millones de euros
desde el final de la guerra fría tanto
finlandia como suecia se han mantenido
no alineadas profundizando los lazos con
la alianza atlántica pero sin ser
miembros en francia el presidente y
candidato a la reelección a manuel macro
ni la ultraderechista marine lepén
acelera su campaña de cara a la segunda
vuelta de estos el 24 de abril de penn
convocó a la prensa para presentar su
programa de política exterior
mencionando el peligro de enviar armas a
ucrania y su voluntad si es elegida
presidenta de impulsar un acercamiento
entre la otan y rusia cuando acabe la
guerra en paralelo a chrome continúa la
defensa de su programa europeísta ya de
alertó de los peligros según el que
entraña la llegada de la ultraderecha
para los franceses
la política exterior también entra en
campaña este miércoles la cantidad de
ultraderechista marine lepén presentó en
parís el programa de política exterior
que implementará en caso de que gane la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones el
próximo 24 de abril lepén destacó que no
saldrá del acuerdo contra el cambio
climático de su voluntad de ampliar el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
de reformar la unión europea desde
dentro y de salir del comando integrado
de la otan pero sin salir de la alianza
transatlántica entre otra de sus
propuestas la candidata de ultraderecha
mencionó que en caso de ser presidenta
liderará las conversaciones para acercar
las posturas entre la otan y rusia
wiggins
tan pronto como termine la guerra rusa
ucraniana y haya sido resuelto por un
tratado de paz leire la implementación
de un acercamiento estratégico entre la
otan y rusia como se había considerado
anteriormente esto es del interés de
francia europa y de eeuu
en el acto comandado por la lideresa
ultraderechista no faltó la polémica con
los periodistas y también con un grupo
de personas que interrumpió el acto y
fue evacuado de la sala la conducta del
epen fue criticada por el president en
una entrevista en la televisión pública
francesa aunque el mandatario prefirió
dedicar la jornada a defender sus
propuestas económicas y sobre medio
ambiente
el decrecimiento económico no está en mi
programa te lo confirmo no va a cambiar
creo que tenemos que crear riqueza para
poder redistribuir y ser más fuertes y
por otro lado la planificación ecológica
es algo con lo que me puedo alimentar
las propuestas sobre la calidad del aire
la calidad del agua el mar son cosas que
son compatibles y que he podido empezar
e ir más allá me interesan estas
propuestas entonces estoy escuchando
el presidente ya había destacado la
importancia de defender su proyecto
europeo
debemos defender el proyecto europeo que
hoy nos corresponde como militantes de
la esperanza como militantes del
humanismo como militantes del futuro
a menos de dos semanas para definir
quién ganará la carrera al elíseo los
candidatos ponen sobre la mesa todas sus
propuestas para atraer a los indecisos y
a los abstencionistas
este miércoles las autoridades
neoyorquinas anunciaron la detención del
sospechoso del tiroteo en el metro que
se saldó con 23 heridos 10 de ellos
afectados por bala un día después de
este incidente considerado como
terrorista la población de la gran
manzana todavía está conmocionada alva
santana tiene los detalles
mis compañeros de nueva york
lo tenemos tras una jornada que
conmocionó a los neoyorquinos y 24 horas
después del tiroteo en el metro de nueva
york la policía metropolitana logró
detener al principal sospechoso del
crimen frank james jesse james son mails
el señor james es un hombre de 62 años
desconocido para nosotros tiene vínculos
en wisconsin ohio pensilvania nueva
jersey y la ciudad de nueva york new
jersey a new yok ser el sospechoso al
que se le imputa el cargo de terrorismo
tiene antecedentes de hecho entre 1992 y
james fue detenido un total de 9 veces
por distintos cargos en especial por
agresión sexual y en base a las
investigaciones en curso el sospechoso
habría alquilado una furgoneta para
llevar a cabo el crimen que se saldó con
más de 20 heridos este miércoles los
neoyorquinos volvieron a utilizar el
metro pero tras lo sucedido muchos
todavía tienen miedo a volver
es horrible quiero decir esto demuestra
que necesitamos más seguridad en las
estaciones de metro y que es muy
angustioso que podría hacer cualquiera
de nosotros que vamos a trabajar cada
día
a pesar de que las autoridades han
llamado a la calma y a la precaución
este crimen en la ciudad estadounidense
ha generado polémica sobre los
mecanismos de seguridad en el país y la
exposición de los ciudadanos
vamos a argentina porque la subida de
precios no da respiro la inflación
interanual en el país en el mes de marzo
fue de un 55% esto respecto al dato de
marzo del año pasado se trata de uno de
los datos más altos a nivel mundial y a
nivel latinoamericano solo se encuentra
por detrás de venezuela alimentos como
el pollo los huevos el pan o el café son
los que más han aumentado su presión por
sectores la educación la ropa o la
vivienda han experimentado los mayores
repuntes andares en este tema vamos a la
provincia de jujuy en argentina allí se
encuentra gabriela de la rosa dirigente
de la organización social polo obrero y
del partido obrero que ha liderado
marchas contra el alto costo de la vida
gabriela gracias por estar con nosotros
cómo se explica esta situación
inflacionaria que además parece estar
golpeando sobre todo a las clases
populares
bueno en argentina gracias primero por
por lado está en argentina o si está
viviendo una situación social muy
compulsiva
nosotros el partido obrero el polo
obrero
viene denunciando que el gobierno de
alberto fernández junto con los
gobiernos de las provincias
descargando sobre la población
trabajadora un ajuste fenomenal
no solamente sobre la base de tarifazos
de rebaja salarial
sino también sobre la base de un aumento
en los precios y en el costo de vida es
así que corre también en los alquileres
obviamente muy fuerte en la canasta
alimentaria
en los en las tarifas del
del transporte público y el sector más
golpeado de la población trabajadora son
los trabajadores que están desocupados o
que están en la informalidad que en
argentina son una gran mayoría
trabajando en la informalidad en la
precarización laboral y los jubilados
junto con los desocupados son quienes
más están padeciendo esta situación
porque nos llegan a comer a cubrir
algunas de las comidas del día y eso
desata una cantidad de familias que
acuden a los comedores populares que son
atendidos por las organizaciones
sociales que salen a movilizarse junto
dentro del movimiento piquetero
combativo que por ejemplo hoy
movilizó en todas las provincias del
país gabriel a ustedes concretamente que
le piden al gobierno para hacer frente a
esa situación
de fondo obviamente pedimos que se deje
de pagar al fondo monetario
internacional- los acuerdos que se han
hecho con el fondo monetario
internacional en argentina todavía
refuerzan un ajuste
el recorte o el ajuste del gasto fiscal
golpea obviamente de lleno a la
población trabajadora que es donde se
supone que hay un gasto social y esto
incluye también a las jubilaciones pero
incluye también obviamente a los
asalariados trabajadores del estado y a
quienes
perciben un beneficio social que en
argentina son los programas sociales
y perdón si gabriela muchísimas gracias
por habernos acompañado con este
comentario aquí en francés 24 vamos a
cambiar de tema en filipinas al menos 67
personas murieron y 28 están
desaparecida después de que una
depresión tropical haya provocado días
de lluvias en el centro y el sur del
país aunque las operaciones de rescate
están en marcha se teme que el número de
muertos aumente
las operaciones de búsqueda y rescate
están en marcha en el centro de
filipinas esto ha sido posible gracias a
la llegada de equipos pesados y que el
clima se ha despejado seis pueblos de la
ciudad de babys se vieron afectados por
desprendimientos de tierra durante el
fin de semana mientras que los equipos
de rescate han empezado a levantar los
cuerpos de las víctimas mortales
[Música]
solo espero que venga a nosotros aunque
sea en nuestros sueños le echo mucho de
menos
esto fue el momento en el que el nuevo
deslizamiento de tierra golpeó la
provincia de leyte el martes la tormenta
tropical media había azotado la zona un
día antes que había provocado
inundaciones y corrimientos de tierra
generalizados los médicos se han
apresurado en atender a los
sobrevivientes al tiempo que las
autoridades locales verifican quiénes
siguen desaparecidos se trata de la
primera tormenta tropical que azota a
filipinas en lo que va del año este país
propenso a las catástrofes suele tener
una media de 20 tormentas al año durante
la estación de los monzones que comienza
en junio pero con el cambio climático
esta nación ha visto como las tormentas
empiezan antes durante el año y según
los científicos su intensidad ha
aumentado
[Aplausos]
terminamos esta emisión con información
deportiva porque finalizaron ya los
cuartos de final de la champions league
en españa' el manchester city empató
contra el atletico de madrid a 0 y en
los de inglaterra que pasan las
semifinales tras su victoria en su
estadio su rival será el real madrid' en
la otra llave el liverpool empató en
anfield contra el benfica a tres goles
de los ingleses superaron la
eliminatoria por un global de seis a
cuatro y se medirán ante el villarreal
de españa por un puesto en la final
y terminamos así esta emisión
informativa que desde la pantalla de
france 24 porque la información continua
[Música]